[Music]
one of the most challenging aspects of
building any app is determining the
optimal data structure ideally you want
to maximize performance while minimizing
costs but that's easier said than done
and especially so with a no SQL database
like firestore because you really have
to plan ahead on how you model your data
last week I asked everybody on our slack
channel to send me the biggest
challenges that they faced modeling data
and firestore and this conversation
snowballed into an entire new course on
fire ship dedicated completely to no SQL
data modeling and queries so this is a
topic you're interested in consider
becoming a pro member to get access to
that course and I'll leave a discount
code in the video description in today's
video we're going to look at five
different ways you can structure and
query your data that you may not know
about and each technique that we'll look
at is based on a real submission from
the community a minute ago I said that
you have to plan ahead when structuring
your data so what do I mean by that
exactly
well the basic idea is that you want to
pre render your data so that it fits the
view or the screen in your app as
closely as possible ideally you only
need to make one document read or one
query to a collection to fill the entire
view with data this differs from a
relational SQL database where the idea
is to break your data into a lot of
small pieces and then join it all
together server-side heard people say
that fires store or no SQL databases in
general are not good for relational data
modeling but that's actually not true
and it's really just a matter of
rethinking the way that you model data
in general and what you'll find is that
you can solve all the same problems that
you can with SQL but you can do it in a
way that's faster less expensive and
more flexible with that being said let's
go ahead and jump into our first data
model and access pattern this suggestion
comes from Samrat and he wants to query
a collection based on whether or not a
user was mentioned in a post in that
collection this is similar to something
like Twitter where if you mention a user
name with the @ symbol it will notify
that user that they've been mentioned
and they also might want to see a list
of all the tweets that they've been
mentioned in in this case we have a
many-to-many relationship where a tweet
can have many mentioned users and a user
can be mentioned in many tweets but the
thing to keep in mind here is that a
tweet or a post can maybe only have one
to 10 mentioned users but a user can be
mentioned in potentially billions of
tweets in situations like this it's
usually best to have the document with
the smaller side of the relational data
manage D relationships in this example
we have an array of usernames embedded
on the tweet or post doc
you'd implement this logic somewhere in
your front-end code using regex to
extract the user names out of the post
text and then duplicate them on the same
document as an array now it becomes very
easy to query all the tweets that a user
is mentioned in by making a reference to
the post collection then we can use the
array contains operator to get all the
tweets that have a corresponding user ID
in that mentions array and then we could
use a cloud function to listen for a new
post to be created and then send a push
notification or an email to a user when
they're mentioned so the main limitation
with array contains is that you can only
query for one item at a time and that
leads me to the next challenge which is
a category system that allows you to
filter by multiple categories at the
same time while also being able to see
if a post contains a given category out
of potentially multiple passed values
and also the ability to filter by not
containing a certain value so these
requirements roughly translate into an
and or or not statement in a sequel
database I'm gonna go ahead and call
these tags instead of categories but the
general idea here is the same we have a
tags collection which is really just
there to hold any extra data about a tag
like a description or a URL or something
like that and I'd recommend giving your
tags a unique ID that's something
descriptive that you can actually show
in the UI and then you'll take that ID
and associate it to a post by using a
map so we have a map called tags and
then each key in that map is the ID from
the tags collection and the cool thing
about firestore is that it automatically
indexes the keys in the map which means
we can query them without any additional
configuration first let's take a look at
how we can do a logical and query or in
other words we want to get all of the
items that have both of these tags
present we can do this by simply
chaining together where statements and
as long as they're using the equal to
operator we can do this as many times as
we want so this works great if you're
filtering by multiple boolean values but
if you throw in a range operator that
means you'll need a composite index and
keep in mind you can only use one range
operator per query so that's a
limitation that you want to consider now
if you wanted to make something that was
more like an or query you can just make
multiple queries for separate tags we're
able to run these queries concurrently
and then we can just join them together
and filter out any duplicates in our
client-side code now the most difficult
part of this challenge is implementing
the knot logic the values on the map are
set up as boyens so the most
straightforward approach here would be
to add all of the tags to every document
and then set them to false by default
this would be perfectly fine if you have
a finite set of
and know their values upfront but it
would be much more challenging if tags
are generated by users and there could
be potentially billions of tags so
that's a limitation to consider but keep
in mind that if you have a numeric value
or if you have a string value with some
sort of ordering and bedded in it and
you can simulate a knock query by using
range operators for example if we wanted
to get all the items that were not
twenty dollars then we could query on
either side of that range or in other
words all the items that are less than
twenty dollars and all the items that
are more than twenty dollars and if
you're doing a lot of stuff like this it
might be time to look into something
like algo Leah to index some of your
data in a full-text search engine that's
what I do for fire ship and firebase in
algo Leah work really well together now
moving on to our next data model this
one comes from Lenny Cunningham and his
flight now dotnet app geolocation
queries bring up a really interesting
data modeling technique called composite
strings not only do composite strings
allow us to do things like geo hashing
but it also allows us to do things like
treat reversals and threaded comments
take a look at this tree structure we
have here where each letter represents a
document in the database what I'm going
to show you next is how to write a query
that will traverse down one node of the
tree and this is especially useful if
you're building something like reddit
comments that can be threaded multiple
levels deep or if you have a hierarchy
of categories and only want to query a
specific node in that tree we can do
this with all of the documents in the
same collection and you can see here at
the top of the tree we have the document
a and it has a parent value set to false
that would be our top-level comment and
then let's say a user responds to this
comment that will be our B document and
it has a parent value set to a now let's
imagine we have a response to the B
document then we would have a C and D
document and they both reference the
same parents of a B so what we've done
here is create a composite key where the
items at the third level of the tree
referenced the IDS of the parent
documents at the first and second levels
these don't need to be an alphabetical
order anything like that you can just
use fire stores automatically generated
IDs the only thing that's important is
that the composite string is created in
the same order that the parent elements
appear in the tree let's take a look at
how we can actually traverse this tree
if we just want to grab the top level of
the tree which you would probably want
to do if you're showing the top level
comments is just query where the parent
equals false now if you want to query
across the breadth of the tree or just
get all of the top level responses or
something like that you can also save a
level property on each document which
would
you to do so but I think most use cases
will require you to query the depth of
the tree so this parts technically
optional then assuming you have the
level property which is just an integer
that increases by one for each level you
can use where to query where all the
documents live at a certain level or you
could use a range operator to get
everything above or below a certain
level now things get a lot more
interesting when we query the depth of
the tree the composite key that we set
up earlier will get larger and larger as
we get deeper in the tree that means we
can take a document ID and use it as a
starting point and then query all of the
children that start with that same ID in
their composite parent string we can
make this query by saying where the
parent is greater than or equal to the
ID and where the parent is less than or
equal to the ID plus a high Unicode
character so that would allow us to
start from any node in the tree and then
traverse downward and this is actually
the same way that geo hashing works and
it's a very powerful feature but is a
little more advanced now moving on to
our next data model which comes from
Stefan we're going to look at how we can
query a collection starting with an
array of document IDs his data model was
a lot more complex but I just wanted to
pick out one little thing that I think
is helpful to a lot of people when
working with firestore it's ideal to
denormalize your data or embed it on a
single document but there are a lot of
cases when it's just not practical or
possible to do that so one thing you can
do is create a more normalized model
like we see here with a sizes array then
each element in that array is a string
referencing a document in a different
collection but because there are no
server-side joins in firestore how do we
actually join this data so we can use it
in our UI we can actually do this very
efficiently in firestore because we can
send multiple read requests to the
database and firestore will handle all
of those requests concurrently here's a
little helper function you can use in
JavaScript to join an array of IDs to a
collection it takes a collection and an
array of IDs as its argument then it
Maps the IDS to a document read that
will give us an array of promises and
then we can use promise dot all to
resolve all of those promises
concurrently and lastly we can map the
document snapshot to its raw data now if
we wanted to use this helper method in
our code we can just pass at this
collection reference and the array of
ID's that we want to read and it will
return an array of the document data so
if you want to model your data in a more
normalized SQL style you can do it using
something like this now that brings us
to the final model coming from Troy and
he's building something like a social
media style follower feed
in other words you follow a bunch of
users and you want to see the most
recent posts from those users that you
follow this is actually a very
challenging requirement so I built a
full demo to show that it's possible in
firestorm as you can see here I'm logged
in as Jeff d23 and when I unfollow these
users their posts are removed from my
feed so basically what we're doing here
is we're grabbing the most recent posts
from these users and then ordering them
by date and on top of that we're also
maintaining the user to user follow
relationship let's start by taking a
look at the data model the only way to
make a system like this scale to a deist
amount of users is to duplicate some
data in our database we have three
collections at play we have one for
users one for posts that can be posted
by a user and then another one for
followers all the relational data will
be handled by the followers collection
and in fact all of the data that you see
in the UI is coming from a query from
the followers document the followers
document belongs to the user who is
being followed and keeps track of all of
the followers in an array but in
addition to keeping track of the
followers it also duplicates some of the
users recent posts it doesn't duplicate
everything it only duplicates the data
that we need to show in the feed like
the title and it may be a preview of
some of the text and the last thing we
need to do is keep a timestamp of the
users last post what we're going to do
is make a query on this last post
property along with the users array and
the result of that will be all these
duplicated posts from the users that the
user is following now an important thing
to point out here is that we're keeping
track of the followers on a single
document so that means we can only scale
up to one megabyte of data and that
means you may need to break this up into
multiple documents as your app grows I'm
going to go ahead and write this query
inside of an async function because
we'll need to do some data wrangling
after we retrieve the initial data first
we'll make a reference to the followers
collection and then we'll query it using
array contains with the username of the
logged in user
after that we'll make this a compound
query by using order by with the last
post timestamp and keep in mind this is
a compound query so it's going to
require an index and firestore we'll
give you a warning about that in the
console now the cool thing about this is
we can limit it to 10 document reads so
it's a very efficient read but it can
provide us with data to populate
potentially dozens of different posts in
the feed once we have the result of this
query we have an array that we need to
then map to the document data and then
on the document data we're going to have
an array of the users most recent posts
and that's what we actually want to
be showing in the view so I'm going to
reduce this array of documents down to a
new array that only contains the recent
posts and then I want to sort those
recent posts based on their published
date we can use a race sort to handle
that and at this point we now have a
sorted array of post that spans across
multiple users that this user is
following I'm gonna go ahead and wrap
things up there if you want to learn
more about data modeling and how these
particular data models work consider
becoming a pro member at fire ship IO to
get access to the course thanks for
watching and I will talk to you soon
[Music]